who takes the credit thank you David
drell I've decided that these
conferences are important and I'm going
to tell you why I'm going to say a word
about what they're about and then i'm
going to introduce pj a long time ago
seven years ago maybe David came to me
and he had this idea and I told us
before but I'll tell it again I said I
don't understand i said do you want to
teach freedom to the Christians or do
you want to teach Christianity to the
heathen and he said we want to teach
freedom to the Christians and I said
good let's do that so that's why you're
here
I think our partners in this actin of
the great people i know a lot of you and
I'm so glad you're here and I'm proud to
work with you we are talking about free
markets and freedom and Christianity and
that's two of the three things that are
in peril today and two of the three
things that give us our lives allow us
to live as human beings third is implied
by the to Christianity is a very curious
religion about politics and law it's a
unique in fact you can see the pattern
the old pattern the regular pattern and
Judaism God gives the law it covers lots
of things that today we think of as
civic private the test is to obey the
law it's not everybody's law it's the
chosen people's law but it's like the
ancient city in this regard the
substance of the relations is in the law
will you keep the law or will you not
the Jews had the hard duty of trying to
keep it and failing of course they were
constantly punished and sometimes
rewarded it's a legal religion Athens is
part of our like that if you want to see
something in modern times like that look
at one of these Islamic Republic's
obedience is the test their laws and
they govern everything Jesus was this
incredibly frustrating guy because he
never did get going get his army up and
get his courts running set up his regime
there's some evidence in the New
Testament that he was crucified because
of disappointment about that he was not
the kind of Messiah that was expected My
Kingdom is not of this world people who
built our country do a deduction from
that more clearly than anyone ever had
before
their deduction was you're going to have
to have government there are some things
that should leave leave alone it's
complicated because we're going to have
wars and we're going to have good
compartment to each other the law is
still going to be a very commanding
thing but it's going to be conceived as
a protectionists of things that each of
us is responsible to do and has a right
to do the regime of civil and religious
liberty was was invented in its full
form here in this country and that point
of view religion is the source of
privacy something our own each
accountable to his maker each free and
fully human to work out there they speak
of the bonding of civil and religious
freedom in the making of the country
property rights is a civil freedom like
relations with God it's written in the
nature of the human being we're
necessitous beings were born with a
brain and a hand the pair of hands and
we have to feed ourselves everybody has
that problem goes on every day all the
time its incessant so the idea was that
as we go about that these are our own
needs we should be protected in the
property that we gather don't mistake
with the most social of all beings save
the classics because we can talk we have
a connection with each other that's
different than any other kind of being
in my family
we have dogs and we watch them all the
time they're our example we have cats
too but I never pay attention to him and
that does anybody want a cat but the
dogs you know they liked it they try to
talk to you one time I said in one of
the dumbest boxers we ever had I said
that look at that dog penny my wife said
he's quivering on the threshold of
understanding and she said doesn't look
to me look much like he's going to cross
it but we do cross that you know and
since we have these needs and we satisfy
them we could trade we could have a form
of cooperation that's profound we could
have the division of labor we could
cooperate in that really close way that
we do whenever we have economic
relations and if we have our property
rights because it's written is the claim
in our nature then we'll get very close
and will produce a lot in markets will
flourish and they can't really be
stopped because free people who own
their own stuff they'll trade it and
they'll work for each other a source of
privacy like religion source of each
person empowered however he's born
whatever station to live a fully human
life I said there were three and the
third is the family because if I are
concerned with God and our property
rights are written in our nature that
word nature comes from the Latin word
for birth and we have a very unusual way
of growing up with human beings takes a
long time to raise our children and now
we have data alas because we live in
such an age where the family is
collapsing I mean it's collapsing fast
all around us half the babies born out
of wedlock and there's data to say that
that's not good
would think what happens in the family
our speaker tonight is hilarious and
eloquent he's always evolved by the way
about family relations makes you giggle
to think about the things he's written
and partly you good because they're so
true because it's hard to raise kids you
know and if somebody doesn't do it they
don't do so well and we can measure that
now another source of privacy because
every mother and every father basically
exercises a Dominion that covers much of
the same ground that a king would have
what should I be how shall I behave how
shall I grow up every mother and every
father answers those questions gives
them a scene of action in which to be
fully a human being now everything that
I just said is not controversial it's
rejected by the academic world today
it's repudiated and increasingly by the
political world in Houston two weeks ago
the city attorney delivered a subpoena
to a bunch of preachers to deliver his
sermons to him so he could investigate
them for a breach of a law governing
political speech and freedom of speech
if it means anything whatsoever it means
freedom to talk about politics and if
the city attorney he was working in a
blue city but if he'd been working in a
blue state then that thing wouldn't have
been quashed by the state attorney
general and we'd be reading these
sermons today and he'd be making charges
about how these people have broken the
law inside their own churches where
everyone who goes as a volunteer in
Maryland it is illegal to deny any
person access to a public bathroom of
whatever gender they are
and heels of college for 171 years this
is 174 it doesn't have coed dorms and
that's an old thing the idea is we're
going to work so closely together we're
going to be colleagues and a college
both those words mean partnership that
we can't be thinking mainly about each
other's bodies especially not now
residence halls is it going to be legal
for us to maintain that institution I
fear but i can tell you because i have
some experience with this now to make a
college productive and fun and happy you
actually have to have agreements about
things like that if that's what you're
arguing about then you're ripping each
other up and you're not really thinking
together and i claim for our college
that's not only true that we don't take
any money from the government direct or
indirect i also claimed that in 1863 you
could look back in the past also when it
wouldn't take any money from the
government the things happen on
battlefields in pennsylvania and they
might have been different we hadn't been
there we didn't ask anything of anybody
to go where they just went because they
loved can you see how that's a reversal
of fundamental civic institutions and
what's become of our right to property
in Connecticut they took a bunch of
people's homes away they were living in
the homes they were old homes couple of
families you've been there for a long
time and what they took him away by the
way they never did anything with the
land they just moved them out but the
plan was they were going to let other
people build commercial buildings on it
they were subsidized so those other
people could make a lot of money and so
that the authorities who proved all this
could make a lot of money because they
wanted the tax rate base up because you
know it's hard to pay for these pensions
these people get
all three of those areas you see
something close to fifty percent of the
children are being born out of wedlock
and we're locked in a great national
debate about how many genders there are
the answer is an infinite number as many
as there are people i think these
conferences are valuable because i'm
looking for friends and i bet you are
too there's a fight it's a fight for
freedom and freedom is valuable for the
things that protects our faith our
property our families our ability to
live as human beings thank you for
coming
so that's enough on these grim subjects
now it's time to make fun of them so my
colleague Carl and I listened on the way
down to the Indianapolis today to one of
the most important works of political
philosophy written in recent times his
title is don't vote it only encourages
the bastards
it begins with a high tone there's a
story about a duchess it concerns
flatulence it also concerns most of the
stories of this man you're going to hear
are the same right in other words
there's some noble and fine thing and
it's dressed up in the subject of
flatulence and this is about two
gentlemen an American an Englishman who
keep taking responsibility for the
outburst and then he proceeds from that
to an apology for his barnyard language
in this particular book uncommon though
it is in his writings and apology you
know means defense and his defense is an
argument he has to be true to his
subject matter politics he was born in
1974 he was born in 1974 in Toledo Ohio
there's a transposition in there
somewhere he went to Miami University of
Ohio and that's because Hillsdale
College was probably too strict he's a
smart and he has contact with fancy
education he is smart very smart he's a
he studied at Johns Hopkins got an MA
and then god help us he becomes a war
correspondent for The Atlantic Monthly
and rolling stone last night I was at a
dinner and somebody quoted a recent
passage from from Rolling Stone and I
looked at him a GOG this person is one
of the last people and almost everybody
I know it's one of the last people I
think would be reading Rowling's done he
said I read every every time said he's
written a lot of books he's hilarious
but there's more to him than that I
although by the way that's enough I'm
not in a long time I admire him very
much and I figured out a while ago some
years ago now that underneath all that
and above all that both he's a serious
man today I listened to him give one of
the clearest and most beautiful
explanations i have ever heard of why
these principles must lead to the
extinction of the human being and the
individuality of the human being it's
just very powerful and it's in between
the Duchess and the three things you
might do to a politician which I at
least will not repeat in this company
one of the best and wisest men I know pj
o'rourke
or gosh to say about that um other than
that's going to be very hard to live up
to um I I want to talk tonight for a
little bit about the political economy
of the baby boom and the baby boom you
see is a great boon to economists the
baby boom allows economists to do the
one thing that they like most the thing
they like even more than they like
disagreeing with each other what the
baby boom you can do is economists can
quantify the baby boom baby boom is
perhaps the one generation in American
history that can be defined with the
kind of precise numbers that economists
love to have you can't do that with the
greatest generation greatest generation
they were defined by the immeasurable
forces of the Great Depression and World
War two you can't do this with
Millennials they are defined by having
their noses stuck in personal
communication devices and and and and no
amount of big data I can tell us what's
up the Millennials noses we just don't
know in fact most groups of people who
get tagged by history as a generation
can only be described in an in precise
way folks sort of the same age
experiencing sort of the same things in
sort of the same place like the cast of
seinfeld a cast of friends lost
generation for instance i am pretty sure
as a result of taking modern literature
in college that Ernest Hemingway eff
scott Fitzgerald James Joyce Gertrude
Stein Henry Miller and Ezra Pound were
roommates in a big apartment on the left
bank in Paris in the 1920s if I happen
to be wrong about that I I give the
sitcom idea free to you members of the
audience
um the baby boom however has an exact
demographic definition we are the
children who are born during the period
after World War two when the long term
trend in fertility among American women
was exceeded now this excess began
promptly in 1946 when the boys got home
from the war and it gradually tapered
off until in 1964 American women were
taking the pill or rover rolling over
and pretending to be asleep or telling
their husbands gophone the Pope for
birth control device huh by the time the
baby boom was done being born 75 million
eight hundred and twenty-one thousand of
us had made our appearance in previously
tidy American homes at the time the
country had a population of 192 million
the baby boom was almost forty percent
of the population I mean no wonder when
we sneeze the nation got the flu and
even now after all the heart attacks
cancers car wrecks suicides and fatal
slips in the bathtub that the actuarial
tables demand we are still a quarter of
the citizenry were America's largest
minority group ever and the political
economic consequences of this minority
group have been momentous mainly in a
form of minority set-asides like Social
Security and Medicare the youngest baby
boomers turned 50 this year I mean the
last of the baby boomers will be 52
end-december now already about
thirty-five percent of the federal
budget goes to those two minority
entitlement programs social security
medicare by 2030 when the last of the
baby boomers is struggling to get the
depends on after the levitra has been
taken my generation will be getting
Social Security and Medicare benefits
equal to half of all the money spent in
Washington we're riding down the highway
of life in a welfare Cadillac now as an
irony in this since the single
greatest formative factor in the baby
booms existence is that we were the
wealthiest generation in geo-economic
history hands down our families had
money albeit speaking for myself and I'm
sure most of you our families didn't
have much money 1947 when when I was
born not 1974 1947 median family income
in america was 3031 dollars a year
that's thirty one thousand seven hundred
dollars in two thousand thirteen dollars
that's on the that thirty one thousand
seven hundred that's only four thousand
one hundred and thirty dollars more than
the 2013 poverty threshold federal
poverty threshold for a family of five
in 1947 to me middle-income was a
blessing of middling proportions but it
was a huge budget a huge blessing
nonetheless the greatest generation our
parents concentrated itself to raising
the country's median income and they
would continue in their devotions by
1964 median household income had reached
nearly forty nine thousand seven hundred
dollars and two thousand thirteen
dollars just in time to sanctify the
baby boom with college education on
absolutely unprecedented scale now let
me pause here to note something that you
especially you The Economist's in the
audience already know the growth of
prosperity for middle-income Americans
oddly hard to measure in the first place
income per se gives us a poor picture of
quality of life and the CPI does more to
obscure than to clarify that picture in
a second place like many things the
government didn't used to be the
government didn't used to be a
statistical busybody the Census Bureau
has no no no figures for median
household income in 1947 now UC Berkeley
economics professor dr. Emmanuel and I'm
hope I'm saying is his right name sighs
am I saying Gary or area is that how you
say his name say he's that's how you
it's how Gary says it okay I'm going
with Gary okay he spent a lot of time
most of the past decade trying to
determine average income in the United
States over history now of course
household income income is not the same
as household income especially in a
two-income household and an average is a
mean and a mean is not a median averages
are blurry statistics their ink smeared
by champagne spills at the top and damp
seeping into empty refrigerator cartons
or homeless people are sleeping at the
bottom that said doctor doctor says
calculates that in years when the
greatest generation was growing up 2013
22 thousand 22 I mean nineteen thirteen
to nineteen thirty-two average annual
income in two thousand thirteen dollars
ranged between about twelve thousand
dollars at its lowest and seventeen
thousand dollars at its highest now you
compare this to the years when the
greatest generation had the baby boom
underfoot 1946 1964 when average income
in two thousand thirteen dollars ranged
between twenty seven thousand dollars
and forty-five thousand dollars it's a
big difference but it's not just the the
quantitative increase that it's
important it's also the volatility from
1946 264 average income climb the social
ladder you know with only the smallest
of slips you know the greatest
generation a very different very
different childhood nineteen thirteen to
nineteen thirty-two average income went
up it went down it went way up it went
way down and the best year and the worst
year were only a couple of years apart
the economy is the kind of a confidence
game and the one abiding characteristic
of the baby boom has been overwhelming
self confidence self confidence has been
way over the top we can do anything I
give you baby boomer Bill Clinton as an
example or Hillary for that matter
that's been the baby boom attitude we we
grew up richer than our parents in a
growing and more stable economy but
maybe an even better measurement of what
gave the baby boom so much confidence
maybe too much confidence is to be found
in simple GDP figures GDP all the money
the people in a country make / all the
people this is statistic that tells us
nothing about our individual economic
circumstances what we eat but it tells
us a lot about our economic atmosphere
what we breathe adjusted for inflation
per capita gdp for the years nineteen
thirteen to nineteen thirty-two it
averages about 8,500 dollars a year as
the average per capita GDP that's the
world of the greatest generation per
capita gdp for the years nineteen forty
six to nineteen sixty-four averages
about eighteen thousand five hundred
dollars this is the world of the baby
boom blood is thicker than water but
gravy is thicker than both the
difference between the manners the mores
the behavior and the attitudes of the
greatest generation of baby boom is ten
thousand dollars you can put an exact
number on it and oh my gosh what that
ten thousand dollars bought in the way
of change we the baby boom are the
generation that changed everything of
all the errors and epics of Americans
ours is the one that made the biggest
impression on ourselves but that's an
important accomplishment because we are
the generation that created the self
made the firmament of the self divided
the light of the self from the darkness
of the self and said let there be self
if you were born between 1946 and 1964
you may have noticed this yourself
before us self with us out was was for
without form and void like our parents
and their dumpy clothes and vague ideas
then we came along now the personal is
the political the personals a
socio-economic the personal is the
religious and the secular the science
and the arts the personal is everything
that creepeth upon the earth after his
and let us hasten to add her kind if the
baby boom has done one thing it is to be
get a personal universe in our apologies
to anyone who personally happens to be a
jerk self is like a fish proverbially
speaking give a man a fish and you have
fed him for a day teach a man to fish
and if he turns into a dry fly
catch-and-release fanatic up to his
liver and icy water pestering trout on
three pound test line on a
one-thousand-dollar graphic graphite rod
well at least his life partner is glad
to have him out of the house so here we
are in the baby boom cosmos formed in
our image personally tailored to our
individual needs and predetermined to be
eternally fresh and novel and we saw
that it was good or pretty good no we
should have had a cooler name you know
like like like that Lost Generation did
you know except good luck to go to
anybody who tries to tell us to get lost
anyway it's too late now we are stuck
with being described as exploding
infants and maybe this time now that we
have splattered ourselves all over the
place for the baby boom to look back and
and think and think what made us who we
are what caused us to act the way we do
and as the kids say WTF because the
truth is if we hadn't decided to be
young forever we would be old we'd be
sad about getting old if we weren't too
busy remarrying younger lives reviving
careers that glass ceilings when
children arrive and renewing for
prescriptions for drugs that keep us
from being said and will never retire we
can't the mortgage is underwater or in
up to the rogaine for the kids college
education and its service serves us
right serves us right we are the
generation who insisted that a passion
for living should replace working for
one hmm still it's an appropriate moment
for us to weigh what we have wrought and
tally what we have added to and
subtracted from existence we've reached
the age of accountability the world is
our fault we are the generation that has
an excuse for everything I to my mind
one of our greatest contributions modern
life but the world is still our fault
and it's just a matter of power and
privilege demography whenever anything
happens anywhere somebody over 50 signs
the bill for it you know and the baby
boom seated at the head of life's table
is hearing Generation X and Generation Y
and the Millennials all saying check
please but there is a problem with
trying to talk about the whole baby boom
at once to address America's baby boom
is to face big broad problems i mean we
number 75 million and we're not only
diverse we take a thorny pride in our
every deviation from the norm even
though we're in therapy for it I we're
all alike in that we each think that we
are very unusual fortunately we are all
alike in our approach to big broad
problems we won't face them there is a
website for that support group to join a
class to take alternative medicine
regular exercise a book that explains it
all a celebrity on TV who's been through
the same thing or we can eliminate
gluten from our diet history is full of
generations that had too many problems
we are the first generation to have too
many answers and that's not a problem I
mean consider the people who have faced
up squarely to the deepest and most
perplexing conundrums of existence I
mean Leo Tolstoy for example toys
Tolstoy tackled every one of these
conundrums and why are we here what kind
of life should we lead the nature of
evil the character of love the essence
of identity salvation
bring death and what did it get him dead
for one thing and in off his rocker for
the last 30 years of his life Plus
Tolstoy was saddled with a thousand page
novel about war and peace and everything
else you can think of which he couldn't
even look up on Wikipedia because he
hadn't written it yet you know what a
life Leo Tolstoy had been a baby boomer
he could have entered a raffle on a baby
boom innovation of the middle 1970s by
the middle 1970s we knew we couldn't run
away from our problems but if we added
cycling and swimming so to the talk to
the problems of talking about the baby
boom let us turn our big broad yet soon
to be firmed up thanks to the triathlon
for seniors that were planning to enter
generational backsides 46 to 64 is a
long time distinctions among different
kinds of baby boomers need to be made
geological distinctions are geographical
I mean I'm sorry geographical
distinctions our mood for us because we
moved around too much and no
distinctions according to race religion
class gender or sexual orientation would
be offensive to baby boom sensitivities
but we are the generation that refused
to grow up so I think a reasonable way
to sort the baby boom is by by high
school class as they were high school
class now the babymoon seniors senior
class we're born the late 1940s I'm a
senior we seniors we were on the bow
wave of the baby booms voyage of
exploration but we were also closely
tethered in the wake of the preceding
generation of greatest generation so in
effect the senior class was keelhauled
by the baby boom experience dragged
under the hall left a bit soggy and
shaken you know so if we wound up as
financial advisers trying to wear hung
studs or as Trotskyites trying to
organize tea party protests or both we
are to be forgiven to put it in the
simplest terms Hillary Clinton and Peach
of Cheech and Chong are both members of
the baby boom senior class
now the juniors the juniors were born in
the early and middle 1950s they were
often younger siblings of the seniors
knee they came of age when parents were
just throwing in the towel you know mom
and dad were too sick of all the
screaming at the dinner table and they
just gave up so the juniors got to
pursue the notion swims and fancies of
the baby boom with an even greater
intensity I mean for them drugs were no
longer experimental drugs were proven
you know John Belushi was a junior
actually John was born in nineteen forty
nine but I knew John and I'm sure he was
held back a couple of years the juniors
were the teeny boppers the groupies the
barefoot urgence of haight ashbury on i
did hunt up some shoes when they
eventually made their way to Silicon
Valley Bill Gates and Steve Jobs who
were both born in 1955 they never did
find their neck ties the sophomores were
born in the late 1950s now by the time
the sophomores reached adolescence the
baby boom ethos had permeated society
sophomore baby boomers had gladly
accepted sex drugs rock and roll and a
deep philosophical underpinnings thereof
but they had seen enough of the baby
boom in action to realize that what
works in general doesn't always work
when the bong sets fire to the beanbag
chair in college many of the sophomores
attended classes some some some even
snuck off and got MBAs now the freshmen
are most interesting group to me the
freshmen were born in the early 1960s
and they felt no visceral effects from
the events that formed the baby boom to
freshmen the Vietnam War was just
something that was inexplicably on TV
all the time like Ed McMahon you know I
mean feminism had gone from a pressing
social issue to mod a TV comedy show
that their parents liked and and and
Martin Luther King was a day off from
work I mean did you see the freshman
take baby boom BS as a given and
speaking
economically here BS has been the
greatest most important economic product
of the babymoon if you don't believe
that just go on the internet just go on
the internet at random punch anything
it's all bs it's all bs is the model of
the baby boom and the freshman baby boom
were born into BS like fish are born
into the ocean they swim in a sea of BS
they have no idea that there's any other
socio-economic environment any dry land
out there it's obvious now my particular
personal favorite baby boomer is our
president born right at the tail end of
the baby boom and a perfect specimen of
the freshman boomer type I was a
wonderful example of his being a frosh
we have to go back to 2008 during
senator obama's campaign for the White
House you may well remember there was a
kerfuffle about the Reverend Jeremiah
Wright Reverend Wright's a man of how
shall we put this strong views strongly
book I think bad word bad word America
the CIA invented aids to kill black
people and so on and so on and so on and
Reverend Wright was the pastor at the
obamas church he'd married Barack and
Michelle he baptized their children well
the Republican Party and outraged
conservatives the right-wing media
screaming on talk radio and Fox TV new
doing nuts over this they were
determined to turn Reverend right into a
major scandal they would end Barack
Obama's political for career forever but
the scandal didn't happen story just sir
peter nod why because of us the baby
boom we realized perfectly well that
while the Reverend Wright was thundering
from the pulpit senator Obama was paying
absolutely no attention at all he was
sitting in a back pew on his blackberry
with Rahm Emanuel you know everything
Reverend Wright had to say went right
past his head you know now my part of
the baby boom the senior class we would
have been standing on a Pew with
clenched fists in the air shouting right
on and demanding vandalism
the nearby university of chicago and the
junior baby boomers assuming they were
awake and time to go to church and
assuming they could find the church they
would have been sitting there nodding
and stoned agreement and hoping the
church's social outreach program
included free lunch and a sophomore baby
boomers they would have been thinking
gosh Reverend Wright i don't i don't
know that might be pitching it a little
high and inside you know but president
obama freshman baby boomer even notice
you know because you know it's all bs in
a vas a socio-economic vision excuse me
to present you the BS of the american
baby boom is the world's future it's the
world's socio political economic future
may take decades may take centuries but
everyone on the planet will turn into a
baby boomer eventually as soon as their
parents get to prosperous and too happy
and begin feeling too much affection for
the kids and start letting them do
anything they want unless of course baby
boom style extravagant freedom scant
responsibility plenty of money and a
monocle piece lead to such a high rate
of worldwide carbon emissions that we
all fryer drowned i can never remember
which it's supposed to be whose global
warming nerve for a while and then we
had a cold winter so now its global
climate change but anyway we may all die
but you can't have everything and you
can have a profusion of opportunity and
at the same time a collapse of
traditional moral strid itional social
standards and I mean collapse of
traditional social standards I mean that
in a good way no more selling your
toddler's as child brides or cutting off
people's hands for shoplifting food for
their families you look at Western
Europe and the wealthiest parts of Asia
and Latin America and they're almost as
useless as as we are again I mean
useless in the best sense of the word
with with abundant disposable income an
ample leisure time to devote to
plateless activities that don't harm
anybody else like fly fishing
you know and it's interesting to me that
baby boom like places all around the
world all seem to be in the same kind of
national political deadlock that we are
here in America arguing about government
benefits versus government costs I mean
as much tut-tutting by pundits about
national political deadlock but it is an
improvement on a certain kind of
national unity Germany wasn't in
national political deadlock on it
marched into Poland in 1939 Japan wasn't
in national political deadlock when it
bombed Pearl Harbor Russia wasn't in
national political deadlock when it's
snatched Crimea give me deadlock anytime
you know see I have foresee a day when
all the world's noxious politics will
disappear because all the world's
political science classes will happily
degenerate into hour-long shouting
matches the way my baby boom political
science class did in 1968 we were
shouting at each other about the war in
Vietnam but I can't remember why we were
shouting at each other about the war in
Vietnam because the students were
against the war the professor's were
against the war the custodial staff was
against the war but that didn't keep us
from shouting at each other why because
we were having fun just like the
Democrats and Republicans are having fun
in Washington right now you know the
baby boom doesn't have noxious politics
communism fascism Islamist Islamists
fanaticism baby boomer he doesn't have
any politics at all we've had three baby
boom presidents so far Bill Clinton
George W Bush Barack Obama you could map
those guys out politically and you'd
have to go to Pyongyang to find somebody
who is more different politically than
they are from each other mmm it's hard
to have politics that are truly noxious
when you like being obnoxious better in
them in the baby boom world of the
future will also enter an economic
Golden Age stupid notions of central
planning nationalization protectionist
trade barriers high regulatory costs
salsa all will fall to the wayside when
everyone is asleep in econ 101
way I was you know they're they're 1.3
billion people in the world living on a
dollar and a quarter a day or less the
way I once was selling pot I smoked all
the profits sooner or later these people
are going to figure out there's a better
way in fact I just received an email
from Nigeria about a rather large amount
of money named transferred to American
bank requiring only modest assistance on
my part there will be no religious
fanaticism in a baby boom world we're
not a generation who listens to anybody
God included now in our defense it is my
faith and conviction that I doubt God
Minds us not bothering him very few of
the people we've bothered parents
College Dean's to police LBJ attractive
types and bars have minded when we quit
bothering them I think God will get over
world peace probably too much to ask but
will be hard to assemble those huge
conscripted armies that used to fight
wars because we'll all have a letter
from our doctor about how we're allergic
to camouflage you know besides war is
about power and interesting thing about
the baby boom is that we're we aren't
power hungry because power comes with
that kicker responsibility or a greedy
you greedy for love happiness experience
sensation thrills praise fame adulation
inner peace and as it turns out money uh
health and fitness too but we're not
greedy for power to observe the baby
boomers who have climbed to the peak of
power in Washington DC are they the best
and brightest know the best and
brightest are over a Goldman Sachs so I
have a message for all the dictators and
despots and autocrats and oligarchs who
rule the worst countries on earth you
will turn in to baby boomers to it shall
reign on your Woodstock you shall spend
your treasure on discos cocaine and
rehab your junk bonds shall default and
your calm and your mortgage lending
bubble shall burst you shall form over
aged garage bands and try to play
Margaritaville your third spouse shall
acquire an American Express black card
with a credit limit higher than the
Greek national debt your daughters shall
our nose rings your son shall have pagan
symbols indelibly marked upon their
necks unless you belong to one of those
cultures where daughters wear nose rings
and sons have pagan symbols and all be
marked upon their necks in which case
they shall not you shall be perplexed by
the Internet you shall grow old and
addled enough to vote for Ron Paul on a
presidential primary there there is no
escape from happiness attention
affection freedom your responsibility
money peace opportunity and thinking
it's all bs behold the baby boom ye
mighty and despair thank you
Thank You mr. O'Rourke we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and a microphone will be brought to
you I know there was an awful I'm awful
moment where you thought I came up here
to give that speech again not going to
do it uncle but I am perfectly willing
to answer some questions anybody has any
questions any kind of question really I
I'm a journalist I'm an instant expert
on anything so ma'am yes sir thank you
for that great talk I'm a little
confused I was conceived during the last
of the sophomore year but born the first
of the freshman year so and both my
parents were first-generation Americans
with their parents all coming from
Eastern Europe so well you see but that
actually makes you yeah what are you um
yeah what that actually makes you in a
way is is more like a senior or a junior
baby boomer because of the culture shock
of having parents come in from out of
town you know and go this is America Wow
so yeah I think that there's a lot of of
what defines being a baby boomers being
in the midst of this change and you
because your circumstances were in the
midst of more change than most people
born and you know around the cusp of the
sophomore what else we got anyone else
out here her face con dr. Arnn
do you think Obama's interested in power
do you think Obama's interested in power
yeah hey to think he's interested just
because I said baby boomers in general
where an interested in power doesn't
mean that specific sorts of them aren't
yeah I mean I think that's all in fact
actually if you think about that's all
liberal politics is really is is I mean
my objection to liberalism is not an
honest it's it's not an honest
disagreement I'm willing to have an
honest disagreement about how much
government should help people who can't
help themselves and how large benefits
and pension should be how much
government infrastructure there ought to
be and so on these are all legitimate
but but the real liberal fundamental
liberal position is to expand government
power upon any excuse whatsoever if you
throw government power out the door of
economics the way we did when the Berlin
Wall class please look this crap just
doesn't work and we pitched we pitched
liberalism out the door of economics we
came right back down the chimney of
environmentalism you know now if you
toss it out the window of fresh air you
know it will crawl in through the crawl
space of like the rape culture on campus
it doesn't matter what the issue is the
point is to make more is to give more
power to government you say well why why
would they want to give more power from
government because every time you give
power to government takes power away
from you so even if you are fond of
power like President Obama or for that
matter all elected officials obviously
are but say you're not an elected
official so why did you want to give
this the this bureaucracy this
government the this you know a
communitarianism why do you want to give
more power over your life because it has
a low threshold of entry low threshold
of entry people out here who are
economists you probably had to get PhDs
probably even did postdoc work you know
those of you who work and business had
to get business degrees you had to know
something you know
doctors lawyers anyone in the
professions even just you know the
person who runs the most modest little
convenience store in the world as a lot
has to know a lot you have to know
anything to go into politics in fact it
seems to help if you don't you know
they're creating a world out there that
spends federal state and local budgets
if you combine them it comes very close
to forty percent of american gdp forty
percent of american gdp is in the hands
of the political process in government
spending we're so these people have
managed to create a world it's like the
it's like the seas students took over
the universe you know they've managed to
create a world with nick and of course
nobody gets anything below a C anymore
so you know what I'm talking about here
it's like you know that the noisy kids
at the back of the class you know
refused to pay attention and chew gum
they've taken over forty percent of our
world you know and they've got forty
percent of this world we have been no
threshold to entry and so that's they to
me is the great danger of liberalism
it's not specific ideas or specific
spending programs sir got someone down
here where's are my coke there when you
get you know how her and baby boomers
the first time you said they avoided
power because it came with
accountability yeah responsibility I can
well the end responsibility
accountability Henry smells like the
beauty of the Obama types as they've
separated the two oh yeah our no
accountability yeah well that's a
typical BS baby one way of approaching
things if you do want power you sure
don't want to attach to accountability
gosh cuz I wouldn't make you accountable
I'm not not look you'd hug the guys he's
not a good president he's not stupid
doesn't want to be accountable for
things so yeah that's and of course
broadening government helps on that
thing to you know bad staff work it was
I don't know how that you know that you
know the government so big who knows
what's going on run over in the Veterans
Administration it's miles from here you
know so uh you know the expansive
government
cuts everybody's accountability in
government too so you see another
advantage ma'am back behind you hi does
it strike you as odd that the person who
wants so much power over America wants
to diminish the power of America well no
it doesn't really surprise me because
the America as a power in the world is
as we all know and I assume there are
some veterans in this room who know it
all too well its burden the kind of
being a world power is not the same as
having personal power when you have
personal power you say go and they goeth
you say come and they cometh you know
when you are in the international thing
you have to bring tanks to make that
happen it is it's like tougher it's like
the real world foreign policies the real
world you know anybody can say anything
they want about foreign policy but
foreign policy is still going to be
dependent on a bunch of nutty foreigners
it's not something you can really run
you know it's not even something you can
run poorly like Obamacare rollout you
know it's something you can't run at all
it's out of your control and dealing
with it means actual use of force means
putting the lives of Americans on the
line it means hiring a bunch of
Republicans because it's what most
military officers are it's let's face it
and you know it's just it's outside the
realm what he wants is fame and
adulation and the spotlight and that
kind of stuff in fact I actually think
we might have here our first celebrity
president I think Clinton had certain
aspects of that to him and doubtless
other presidents have to but I think we
have here our first true celebrity you
know I mean wants to his approach to
to world powers or the Angelina Jolie
approached world par let's think about
nice things and do a little charity work
I'm not going to happen sir congrats for
your depth and width but thank you your
stunt is identified as a as a
libertarian and you picked on others but
after you heard Larry on speak about
faith and family and is anything you can
say about how to libertarians how can
constructive thing you know criticism
how the traits of the baby boomers
affect libertarians and how can they be
more effective you know the political
theory on well one of the nice things
about the baby boom is that it has if in
practice less than in theory a strong
libertarian streak and I take that
largely to be a good thing my core
argument with libertarianism actually
has to do with the faith saying say I do
not think that libertarians give the
kind of weight that they should to faith
libertarians want everything to be
worked out they want their rigidly
logical they want everything to be
worked out logically we all know one of
the reasons that we have faith is that
we know life is beyond our own personal
understanding and we don't think things
just sort of got here by accident and we
can arrange them all you know I mean the
idea that the God didn't create the
world to me has always been like the
idea that you would throw some eggs and
some cheese and some mushrooms and a hot
skillet on the floor and get an omelet
you know I mean I just don't you know
everything about the universe speaks to
creation and organization and we
understand a lot more about that
universe than we ever did before but
we'll never understand all that is
beyond the mind of man and
libertarianism as a tendency not
universal but a tendency to regard the
affairs of Man
as being fully comprehensive to man and
I I spent 20 years as a foreign
correspondent I've just seen too much
inexplicable behavior to believe that
man is fully explicable demand you know
some sir to what degree do you think
teaching in the area of responsibility
and character trait has been neglected
by the baby boomer generation and not
only in the home but in the school
system primary secondary university
level and why did that happen well I
think the essentially the why first I
think it is stipulated than it did
happen but many of us have spent a lot
of our child raising years trying to
make sure it didn't happen to our
children either by sending them to
private schools or to religious schools
many many of which we can barely if at
all afford but the but why is because
the baby boomers came of age as
Millennials are now a time of extremely
rapid and complex change the huge growth
of the American economy after World War
two change is hard for people to deal
with it uh them a little bit from from
from there it's harder to exert
Authority or submit to Authority in a
changing world than it is in an
unchanging world uh you know I always
tell my kids in order to command you
must first learn to obey but that's
really a very Victorian idea I mean
somebody like Winston Churchill had no
problem with the idea of in order to
command you must first learn to obey but
with things changing so quickly mores as
well as economic circumstances I think
it left us a little tough in slightly
tough position where we were both not
willing to confused about right and
wrong and willing
to even say what we did believe about
right and wrong for fear of discipline
and I don't think this was helped by the
fact that there was a great wrong in
America great in persistent wrong of a
racial discrimination and religious
discrimination too I'm old enough to
remember showing up for pick up a girl
for a date in Boston having her parents
or choke on my last name you know
because I was obviously Catholic and
tremendous anti-semitism but of course
first and foremost and greatest of all
was the racism racial attitudes not only
attitudes but laws and all the rest that
went with that I grew up in a world
Irish working class lower middle class
world were words that we would never in
the world speak today were common over
the dinner table just as today certain
words are common over the dinner table
that my parents would have rather died
and had said all about but uh but not to
give it a moral equivalence that's one
of the things that I undercut our own
faith in right and wrong we had been so
wrong for so long about that one subject
that it shook us a little bit in our
faith in other subjects it didn't help
that the mainstream Protestant churches
went all gooey honest it didn't help
that we had the Vietnam War and there
certainly were two sides to that
argument so it's a period of moral
uncertainties this becomes very hard and
I think that you know school systems
gave in to this moral uncertainty and
you really can't blame them their public
institutions are answerable to also i
got all sorts of people picking on them
at all different ways and i think that
some teachers gave up on it too and
that's really the sad part because all
of us especially the older people among
us if we go back to our education i'll
bet each and every one of us there was
just one or two teachers that we had
from kindergarten through college that
really really made a huge difference for
us they may not even have been in our
subject of focus or expert
you know it's and it's those people that
that we lost a little bit you know that
we're you know perhaps afraid to speak
out or and so yeah we certainly created
a system discouraged more of those
people questions Thank You mr. O'Rourke
be very well
we will be back in this room in the
morning at eight fifteen for our first
panel session which is on bitcoins and
if that's a mystery to you it's a
mystery to a lot of us and we're going
to figure it out so we will see you in
the morning enjoy your evening